5 55 on your wednesday morning a viewer
question about a temporary road sign it
is this one right here and fran writes
on my way to work there's a sign on di
between boulder highway and sandhill
saying find alternate route 823 but i
can't find anything online about this i
need to know so i can plan that
alternate route well friend it sounds
like you were headed west on di but
there's a sign with the exact same
message on the east side just after sand
hill
even though my camera makes the sign
look like a studio 54 disco bull the
message is clear to drivers
desert in closed starting 8 23 21 seek
alt route
well di is closing because this bridge
is about to go away
oh oh well as a certain politician
sometimes says look
here's the deal
as part of the year and a half long
project to fix up the 95 515 between the
spaghetti bowl and flamingo the bridge
over di is going to be rebuilt the
closure of di is scheduled to last from
next monday to late next saturday night
nevada department of transportation's
website dedicated to the project says
the closure is the first phase of
demolition second phase will require
another six day closure that's currently
scheduled for about a month from now we
have a link to the n dot website i515
project dot com as well as possible
detours on our website along with all of
our driving you crazy stories eight news
now dot com click traffic then driving
you crazy thanks for writing friend
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone something's driving you
crazy email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com